friends of ours
Belgian friends of ours had a Renault
lekar that they were selling $300
brother and I went in on it together
truly one of the greatest shames of my
life and this is no lie is that I got
vanity license plates for my lekar that
were Lissette so I had a look car with
Lissa vanity license plates that I used
to drive to high school my first job I
was a delivery driver for a sub shop in
New England sub shop chain called
D'Angelo's and that was my first job and
pretty much all you needed was a pulse
in a car and I was lucky enough to have
both and I listen to books on tape that
was what I would do I remember listening
to Michael Caine's autobiography as read
by Michael Caine one summer that was the
the level of uncool I was in high school
is that I did not use that time to blast
the songs of the summer but rather to
listen to PJ Woodhouse on tape I don't
think there's a single thing I learned
at that job except showing up on time
you can learn anything from your first
job at that but attendance is mandatory
but it was great because it was you got
paid both a salary and tips and so when
you got like a big order when like an
office would order lunch and a cookie
you know a hundred dollars where the
subs like you would I mean you have a
real high about that you'd be driving
off he liked it they even if these
people are full tickets and get 10 bucks
here so I will say that my friends were
very aware hyper where I would say of
how much I smelled like onions all the
time for three months straight
this is not a good shoe care for me